Hello and welcome,
everyone. It is September 1,
2023. We're here in active inference
math stream number 6.1 here with Sean
Toll. We'll be hearing a presentation,
active inference in string diagrams
followed by a discussion. This is super
exciting. So if you're watching Live,
please feel feel free to write your
questions in the Live chat. Really
looking forward to this. So thank you,
Sean, again for joining and to you for
the presentation. All right, thanks very
much. Thanks everyone who's watching.
And thanks to the organizers for this
chance to speak to you and to Daniel for
getting in touch and inviting me to
speak. So, yeah, I'm really excited to
share this work with this community,
basically, and to hear from those people
who work with active inference and do
any formal work, what they think of what
I'll present today. So I'm going to be
presenting a formal approach to how you
can describe active inference in terms
of an entirely graphical language called
the language of string diagrams. And
it's based on this mathematics called
category theory. And I won't assume that
you're too familiar with this already
and try and introduce it to you in the
talk. And ultimately, I'd like to sort
of convince you that this diagrammatic
language will be really useful for those
of you who work formally with active
inference and encourage you to pick it
up in your own work. I've just
introduced myself a bit. I'm Sean Tull.
I'm a researcher at Continuum,
formerly a postdoc in computer science
in Oxford, and a Continuum in this
Oxford team where I'm based, where we
study what we call compositional
intelligence, which includes applying
category theory to topics in AI and
as well as this. The project was
supported by a grant from FQXi. It's
located at the bottom and hosted at
Topos Institute, which is the center for
Applied Category Theory.
So let me get think. So,
yeah, here we go. So for active
inference, won't spend too much time
introducing it. I'll assume most people
here are familiar with it, and many of
you probably know more about it than I
do, in fact. So I'll just
mention the parts of it that I'll be
addressing in the talk. So thinking of
it as a model of cognition that simply
we can think of as applying at many
levels, say from a whole organism or
just to a single neuron. And the key
idea is that in this approach, you think
of an agent that's coming with this
generative model that it uses to explain
the observations it receives from the
world in terms of some hidden states,
which you might call perception, and in
terms of its own actions. And in
active inference, it achieves both of
these things through this form of
Bayesian inference or an approximate
form of Bayesian inference by minimizing
this quantity called free energy. And
these are the ingredients we'll be
talking about in the talk. And the thing
that's really exciting about active
inference, I think, for those of a
formal background as well, is that it
aims to offer like a very principled
approach to cognition that you can
hopefully apply at all these many
levels. But I think at the moment it
could also benefit from more formal
work. And that's what this talks about.
It's about formal approaches to the
theory in particular, I think nice
clear formatations or active instances
would help to clarify sort of what the
core of the key ideas of the theory are.
So we'd like it to be this very succinct
principle that ideally we just apply to
a generative model and everything else
follows from. And once we've got to
this, we can hopefully generalize it,
understand it better, and also make it
just more accessible to those who come
from formal backgrounds, like in
mathematics and so on, and get them
working on the topic very quickly and
connect it with approaches in artificial
intelligence as well. But the most
important thing about a good
formalization, I think, should just be
to make learning about active inference
easier, make the framework simpler to
understand. So that's what we're aiming
for in this work. And I'd say in
other places already there's been some
calls that some suggestions that an is
formalization of active inference should
be a diagrammatic one. So when you look
at the generative models that come up in
active inference a lot, they're very
compositional in their nature and it's
very natural to draw them in diagrams.
So it would be nice if our whole
approach to describing it could be
graphical in this way. So just for
example, there's this paper called The
Graphical Brain by Kristen Par, and in
general, we've probably seen loads of
these diagrams describing generative
models where you draw many compositional
features of different spaces of hidden
states, observations, interacting and so
on. So these diagrams
are used, but they're just used to
represent the model. You still have to
then go to doing sort of traditional
probability of theory calculations when
you reason about them normally. But in
fact, there is a whole graphical,
formalism and mathematical language for
describing these kind of interacting
processes just entirely with the
diagrams. So the area of mathematics is
called category theory and the language
are these string diagrams I'm going to
talk today, and in particular, there's a
lot of work going on in applied category
theory now in how you can describe
aspects of probability theory and
causality and causal models in terms of
string diagrams. And these causal models
are basically based on Bayesian
networks. So the same formal structure
as the generative models in active
inference. And in particular, what I'll
talk about today kind of draws on this
paper co authored with Robin Lorenz,
talking about causal models in the sense
of pearl in terms of these string
diagrams. So it's basically causal
Bayesian networks, which is the same
formal structure as we'll be talking
about today. So in this talk I'm
talking about this paper, which was
joint work with Johannes Kleiner and
Ive, which is called Active Inference in
String Diagrams, a categorical account
of processing and free energy. And
basically what we do is try to give a
formalization of active inference that's
nice and clear conceptually just
entirely in terms of string diagrams.
So we're basically taking the kind of
formal content that's in something like
the active inference book and turning it
into these diagrams. And as
I mentioned, it was done as part of this
FQXi project that was actually on a
project about consciousness as about
ways that category theory can be applied
to theories of consciousness. And we've
done some previous work looking at the
integrated information theory of
consciousness and of course there's all
sorts of ways that active inference has
been proposed to connect to
consciousness. But for the purpose of
this talk, we won't go into any of that.
It's just a theory of cognition. I take
it to be here and I'll just mention at
the end it'd be nice to connect it back
up to consciousness in future. And
there's also lots of other related work
going on in category theory that's very
close to this, that often goes by the
name of categorical cybernetics, and
this might include some of the things
Toby has talked about on the stream in
the past. So what I'll do now is
introduce categories and string diagrams
and then later we'll apply them to all
these basic ingredients of active
inference that I've alluded to so far.
So that would be generative models
updating them, free energy and active
inference itself. Let's start
with these categories and string
diagrams. So you can think of a category
in general as a sort of world of
interacting processes. And the
categories we're talking about here are
always going to be these symmetric
minoidal categories. But don't worry too
much about the formal language because
the way we talk about them is just going
to come down to the diagrams here today.
So a category amounts to a collection of
these objects, or sometimes called
systems, like this Capital ABC here,
and what are called morphisms, or you
might want to typically call processes
between them. So when you're writing
normally, you can just write a morphism
from A to B as like this f colon A to B.
In string diagrams, though, you draw it
like this, where we're reading all the
diagrams from bottom to top in this
talk. So you have a wire for the A input
at the bottom and a wire for the B
output at the top. And the morphism is
just drawn as a box F here and you just
read the diagram up thinking about,
okay, it takes in this input coming in
on this wire, a process applies and then
you have your output of type B at the
top. So what you can do with
these processes is compose them. So if
you have two processes, say your F from
A to B and G from B to C, so the types
line up, you can just compose them in
sequence. And this just means plugging
the boxes together in your diagrams.
And because we're in this Minoidal
category, you can also compose in
parallel. So you have this operation
called the tensor, which means given two
objects, you can put them together to
build this composite object. So AB goes
to a tensor B, you'd say, and you can
also do this to morphisms, so you can
build this F tensor G. But in the
pictures it just means drawing them side
by side. And you just think of this as
meaning we have F from A to C and G from
B to D, and they're just running in
parallel and they're not interacting
essentially. So most of the time you
just draw a picture like this and you
don't even need to write the tensor
symbols. So if these two basic modes of
composition and from these you can build
much more elaborate string diagrams in
your category. So if you're writing
things very mathematically, you have to
write lots of equations that a category
or Minoidal category needs to satisfy.
But when you're working the diagrams,
they basically do some of the work for
you because these things just come out
for free. So, for example, you have
equations like this that you'd have to
think about when you're working with
them in the conventional mathematical
way. But in the diagrams it just means
if you have two boxes, you can kind of
slide them along the wires. It doesn't
really matter where they are on the
wires, it tends to just be the
connectivity that matters. Similarly,
we can cross wires over each other
because we're in the symmetric setting
and there's a few just useful features
that you'll have in a category. So every
object comes with this identity
morphism, which you just think of as
meaning nothing happening basically. So
it's just drawn as a blank wire.
There's also a kind of identity object,
as it were, called a unit object, which
is just empty space, so you don't even
draw the wire. This dashbox just means
nothing. It's meant to be an empty
picture. And the latter thing is just
useful because it now means we can talk
about amorphism, which doesn't even have
an input or an output. More formally,
it has this object I as it's input by
output, and we give these things special
names. So the most important one
probably is that of a state,
which is a morphism with no input, as it
were, or really with input I. So in the
pictures it just looks like this. So
there's no wire going in. And you'd call
this a state of A. You can also have a
process that takes in a if it has no
output that you'd call an effect. And if
you have naive, you just call this a
scalar. So this is just going to be like
a number basically floating around next
to your diagram.
So there are many categories out there.
The point of category three is extremely
general. So this could be talking about
computational processes or physical
processes or quantum processes in
particular, and all sorts of things.
For this talk we'll only actually need
about one category. We'll just keep it
simple with this one. That's the
category. I call it matar plus. So it's
positive real matrices. So you can just
take objects for the wires to be finite
sets and the morphisms to be positive
matrices indexed by these, as I'll
explain. So if we draw a box like this,
M, going from X to Y, this is like a
matrix indexed by X and Y. And for each
input in this little set X, sorry, in
the set X and each output in Y, you'd
get a positive real number and we'll
write it like M of Y given X.
So this box would mean a function like
this. Now, when we plug them together,
they let us turn some things that you
normally have to do with equations into
kind of simpler pictures. I mean,
mainly this middle one. So if we have
two in sequence, we just compose them by
matrix multiplication. So instead of
having to write this formula where we
sum over Y, we can just draw this
picture above it where we just plug them
on top. And if we run them in parallel
here, we take the cartesian product of
the sets and the tensor product of the
matrices, as it were. But it's just the
obvious thing where you have two things
running independently. So in
particular a state tier ends up the
minority unit is just a singleton set
and you can basically just ignore it.
So a state tier amounts to just a
function sending each X to a positive
real and affect the same thing. And a
scalar would just be a positive real.
The intuition though is that we're going
to restrict the particular morphisms in
here, which are probabilistic in the
nature. So they need to send each X to
an actual distribution over Y. So I want
to talk about how you actually pick
those up next. So to do that, you use
some extra structure that this category
has. It forms what's called a copy
discard category. So this is one more
bit of mathematical sort of gadgets we
have around. So that is that each object
comes with these distinguished
processes. There's one that we call copy
that takes in a say and brings up two
copies of A at the top and one called
discard where you just throw A away so
you have no output at the top.
These satisfy some equations that are
quite intuitive if you think about like
copying and then throwing away one of
the outputs is the same as doing
nothing. So it's. This blank wire
copying is symmetric and associative is
the last one. So in this category, mad
or plus discard would be just the
function sending each element to one.
And the copy would be like a delta. So A
comes in and two copies of A come out.
At the top is the intuition. The reason
we introduced this stuff is because it's
been shown recently that you can do a
lot of probability theory just in terms
of these CD categories and particular
ones called Markov categories. So
there's a lot of what's going on in
applied category theory at the moment,
using this language of CD categories in
particular, they let you pick out some
things to do with probability theory.
I'll just talk about a couple of them
here. The most important one is the
notion of a channel. So this is what
lets us pick out the actual normalized
matrices, as it were, from earlier. So
in general, you call amorphism a channel
when it preserves this discarding. And a
special case is a state in which when
it's a channel, you call it normalized.
So for a state, this means it would
actually be a probability distribution.
So it's actually normalized if you sum
over the values with this omega, you'll
get one. And for a morphism being a
channel, it means it sends each input to
a distribution. So it actually is a
probability channel in the usual sense.
Equivalently, the matrix for F would be
stochastic. So these are the ones we'll
use in generative models, for example.
And as I said, there's lots of
probability theory you can describe with
these diagrams. It's very two simple
examples. You can describe
marginalization in probability theory
with this discarding thing. So if you
have box omega like this, it would be a
joint distribution over X and Y. If you
just discard Y, you'll get the marginal
on X. And if you plug omega A
distribution on X into an effect, that
would just be any function on X, this
would be giving you a scalar now, and
that would be the expectation value of E
in this distribution. So I'll meet lots
more of this as we go, but let's
actually start doing some stuff related
to active inference in particular now.
So I want to talk about generative
models and how you view these in the
diagrams. So, as we've said, we're going
to be talking about agents having
generative models that relate things
like actions, observations and world
states. And these are normally quite
compositional in active inference,
right, and might involve many different
spaces of states and observations and
these processes relating them. You'd
usually treat these as something like a
Bayesian network, claiming you can view
it really as a causal Bayesian network
because it's sort of describing how
states are causing these observations.
Formally, it's the same thing. It's just
Bayesian network, which you could
normally say is described as something
like a dag, a directed asynchronous
graph, which describe the different
variables that are being related and
then sets the values for each and
probability channels, describing each
one in terms of its parents in the Dag.
And then you often look at its whole
distribution over all the variables.
But already I'd say the way that these
visual networks are drawn in active
inference text and stuff is kind of
converging on something a bit closer to
string diagrams because you don't
actually just draw the Dag and the
variables. It's very useful to actually
give names to the mechanisms themselves,
as it were, like you have in this
picture, the A and the B's. So yeah, my
claim is that it's sort of converging on
the way that string diagrams will look,
as we'll see on the next slide, which is
where you really do label everything,
not just the variables.
So to describe those sort of Bayesian
networks with string diagrams, the key
observation is really that Dags
correspond to a certain class of string
diagrams that we're called network
diagrams. There's a definition here,
but which is better just to see an
example in a second. But the diagrams
built from copying and sometimes
discarding and the key thing is just
that they only have processes with maybe
many inputs but only one output. So this
is going to be like a mechanism that
produces each variable. So the result is
that if you have a Dag G and you choose
some of the vertices to be outputs, so
those are like the observed variables,
you can draw a network diagram which
expresses the same equivalent structure
with those things as the outputs. So
here's an example. We have a Dag with
these four variables, x one to x four.
And what you do is you have a wire for
each variable in your diagram on the
right and you draw a box that produces
it. It doesn't really matter what you
label the box. So this
box C, for example, produces x two and
it will produce it in terms of its
parents in the Dag. So x one and x four
in this case. And if it doesn't have any
parents, it would just be a state, as it
were, box and no input. And then what
you do is you take each variable and you
copy it and you pass it to all of its
children in the Dag and also out of the
diagram if it's an output. So this now
means you've sort of expressed the whole
structure of the Dag and also which
variables are sort of leaving the system
for the output ones. So this allows us
to turn Dag into a string diagram and
then if we want to make a generative
model that expresses like a Bayesian
network that's structured according to
this Dag, you just have to now interpret
this diagram in a certain sense. So in
general, working in any one of these CD
categories, this copy discard
categories, we can say that a generative
model in there is given by one of these
network diagrams without any inputs and
an interpretation of the diagram.
Meaning you actually say what the
objects are for each of the wires in the
diagram and what the actual channels
are. So they need to be channels, not
just morphisms in your category are for
each of the boxes. So for a gender model
like this, you would say you pick
objects x one, x two, x two, x four and
pick channels for the ABCD. And we'll
think of the output of the diagram as
like the observed variables and the rest
of the hidden ones. So for example, if
you're working in this category, Mat R
Plus, that is the only category I've
actually introduced here. So this is
going to be our running example. This is
the same thing as one of these causal
Bayesian networks. So it just means
picking sets of values for variables and
picking probability channels for the
boxes. So you might ask why
would you use this representation rather
than the usual one, which I think is a
good question. So it's equivalent to the
Dag and probability channel description.
But the thing that's nice is that in the
conventional approach of these networks,
you sort of have to switch between the
Dags, which are split the variables and
then doing calculations with
probabilities, whereas in the
categorical approach you can use just
one formatism because you can do
probability theory with the string
diagrams as well. So it's quite natural
in that sense. You have this one
language of both just intuitively
drawing what's going on in a model and
then reasoning about it. It also lets
you start to generalize things in a
useful way, I think. So I kept having to
say that you have no inputs to your
diagram, but there's nothing really
fundamental about that and it's not
really clear why we need that. What you
can do instead is start to allow inputs
to your model as well. So we'll call
this an open generative model. So an
open generative model is the same thing.
But now I've just dropped this
requirement, the diagram doesn't have
any inputs. So here's an example of a
general network diagram. Now, with these
inputs x two, x three. So there's no
mechanism specified for these new
variables, x two, x three. They're just
input variables to the system and they
can be outputs as well. For example, x
three is both an input and an output
here. And again, an interpretation of
this general network diagram just means
picking the objects and the channels.
This is the same definition we use to
define what we call an open calls and
model in the paper with Robin Lorenz I
mentioned earlier. So an emergenerative
model is formally just the same thing,
but we're just thinking of it as a
generative model possessed by a
cognitive agent. If you run this
definition in mathar plus then this is
just like a causal Bayern network. But
now you have some of your variables just
have no mechanism specified. So they're
just inputs to the whole thing.
The nice thing about these open
generative models is that because they
can have these inputs, you can plug them
together and compose them. These things
in fact form their own category. But I
won't go into that today.
So that was the general theory of these
generative models that just actually
described some examples that you'll see
in active inference coming up all the
time. So it's a simple example. Let's
just imagine we have one space of hidden
states and one space of observations.
Then it would be generative model of
that form would just look like this
network diagram where there's just two
wires, there's just S and O. S doesn't
have any parents, so it just has this
prior distribution sigma over it. And
there's just this one channel often
called the likelihood from S to O. If
you just draw that network diagram, say
that model in C or in Matar plus it
would be the same as one of these simple
generative models. When you're looking
at these, you're often introduced
interested in this distribution over
both variables together. This joint
distribution that you might write as P
of S times P of O given S normally or
bit more specifically here introducing
the names for the two distribution in
the channel here in string diagrams,
it's just the same as this. So you just
take the prior and you make it an output
now. And then you compose those channels
together and this would give you a
distribution. So a normalized state M
over snow at this. So this is just the
resulting joint distribution you get
from the generative model. And we'll
come back to that later.
So, a more elaborate example of
generative model that you'll see example
in the active infants textbook are these
discrete time models that are used a
lot. So I'll walk through this diagram
now, so this is an example of a more
complex network diagram and a generative
model it describes. So here we've got
these end time steps going. Remember,
we read from bottom to top, but I'll
just talk about I'll describe things
from the top down here. So at the top we
have the observations one, two up to on
the observations at each time being
caused by these hidden states s one, S
two and SN at each time by these
channels A. And the hidden
state is evolving over time by this
transition channel B, where it takes the
previous state as an input and then
choose the next one. It also takes us
one extra wire that's coming from the
bottom and that's this space P of
policies, which is how the agent sort of
actions enter the picture. So these
policies describe its behaviors, its
behavioral policies it can carry out.
So, based on the previous hidden state
and the way it's acting. This channel B
would determine the probabilities for
the next states and then there's
supplier over the policies that you can
think of as the habits or the typical
behaviors of the system. So you can just
draw this diagram and say, like,
interpret this in math plus and that
would for any given interpretation,
meaning any choice of what the values
for these variables can possibly take
are. And any choice for what these
channels are would then give you this
type of punitive model.
And often you will see models sort of of
this form or similar forms being plugged
together to form these hierarchical
models. And I think the compositional
language is very nice for these because
you really want to talk about open
models to define this so hierarchical
model you can view as really as just
being given by taking lots of these open
generative models I mentioned and
plugging them together in a certain
sense. So here you can see a picture of
a hierarchical model where we just have
these layers where different copies of
the same model at each layer and the
inputs from one layer match the outputs
of the layer below so we can compose
them together. So that's generative
models. So so far we've just been using
the diagrams to represent them. We'd
like to actually do a bit more though
and reason about these models. In
particular, we'll talk about how you
update a model or update the beliefs
within a model, which is very important
in active inference and how this looks
in the string diagrams. Now, so let's
say we've got an agent M, we have a
model M and it's just a simple one
where we say there's just one space of
hidden space S and one space of
observations O. So they have this joint
distribution that I mentioned earlier
and they had these prior beliefs about s
which you can get back from the joint
distribution by just taking the
marginal, if you like. So that's sigma.
So they've got their model, they've got
their beliefs about what states are
likely and then they receive a new
observation. And here the kind of
observations we'll think about in
general can be soft, meaning they're
described by a distribution over O, not
necessarily just one element. So that
would be one of these normalized states.
I'll try not to use the word state here
because it's a bit confusing with this S
around. So this distribution over O is
their new observation, this bold font O.
And now they want to update the margin,
want to update M in some way so that the
marginal basically is different and
describes the updated posterior beliefs.
And this comes up of course in
perception where you're updating your
sort of state of the world given some
observation you receive. But it could
also be used to model like planning
behavior where updating your plan of
action, your policy given something
like. Which outcomes you'd like to see
in the future and we'll come back to
that later in the talk. So we want
to talk about how you can do this
updating. So you might think there's
just a standard answer or at least in
the ideal case, which is this Bayesian
updating. And that's true when your
observations are sharp. We'll start by
talking about that case. So I'll say
what sharp means in a second. But first
I'll just talk about how you treat
Bayesian conditioning in these string
diagrams. So on the right here we have
if you view this process from O to S,
this describes the sort of Bayesian
conditional channel, or in general a
partial channel in fact that the agent
would have from the introduced by their
model. So you can describe this in
string diagrams with a couple of extra
gadgets I hadn't mentioned yet. So you
have your distribution m over S and O.
You can have this in math there's this
effect that we call the cat which just
takes two inputs and compares if they're
equal. This allows for you to turn an
output into an input. So that's what
this part here is. And then you can
introduce this extra thing of
normalization. So what you'd like to do
is take a general morphism and for each
possible input normalize that so that
it's a distribution if you can or set it
to zero if it's just zero and there's
nothing you can do, that's what this
blue dash box is. And in the paper and
in the related calls and models paper,
we talk about the axioms normalization
feature satisfies. The point is if you
compute this thing in Matar Plus, it
will give you kind of what you'd expect.
So it will give you the usual notion for
each .0 of the space O,
you plug it into this, you'll get a kind
of conditional M of S given O that
you'd expect whenever that's defined.
There's a strange diagram way to
describe this kind of Bayesian
conditional channel or partial channel.
And I said this is what you would use
when your observation is sharp. And I
also drew it differently with this
triangle to sort of distinguish that
case. So what does that mean in general?
You say that a state in one of these CD
categories, so a distribution basically
would be sharp when it's copied by the
copy map, which isn't true for general
distributions. And if you run this
definition in math or plus, this really
means that this thing O really is just
point distribution at some specific
element of O. So it really is sharp in
that sense. It's just a point. There's
no real probabilities probabilistic
aspects to it there. But in any CP
category you can just talk about the
sharp states like this. They're often
also called deterministic. So for these
sharp ones, you ideally think you'd like
to do the spacing updating. But in fact
when you've got soft ones. So it doesn't
have this property. There's actually at
least two good ways to do this kind of
updating. I don't know if this is as
well known, so I'll just mention it now
anyway, and they've been studied in some
detail by Bart Jacobs, this paper at the
bottom. So let's say you don't get one
of these sharp observations. You have
just a distribution over o. There's at
least two reasonable ways to generalize
sort of the picture from the last slide
to give a notion of updating. And Jacobs
calls them Jeffries and Pearl's update
rules. So in Jefferies Update,
you basically do it like we did before.
You have this Bayesian conditional kind
of channel or partial channel, the
normalized box here, and you just plug a
distribution into it. But in Pearl's
Update, you turn a distribution into an
effect. So you just compose it with this
cap to bend it around in the picture.
That's what it means. So you plug that
into M and then normalize everything.
So the difference is where the
normalization happens. And yes,
it's basically just interesting that
both of these are reasonable notions,
generalization, they have different
properties. It's not obvious that one of
them is sort of more rational or
something than the other. They just
behave a bit differently. In the formula
you can see that the normalization is
being applied differently. So if you
turn this picture into these little
notations, it would look like this. So
in the top case you're normalizing for
each possible sharp o and then taking an
expectation over this distribution here.
Whereas in the Pearl case, you plug the
whole thing together and then just
normalize. Either way you do it though,
the point is that these things are
actually hard to compute. So we don't
expect a cognitive agent to be doing
either of these exactly, even in the
sharp case. And so, as we know, we want
to instead approximate these kind of
things using free energy, which is what
I'll talk about next.
So our aim is to try and accommodate
free energy somehow in the diagrammatic
approach and free energy sort of formula
that come up are often given in terms of
what you call the Surprise, these
negative logarithm quantities. So we'll
start by introducing just a new
graphical component for treating those
that we call log boxes. If you have any
function E on a set X, a positive
real, remember that made in A, that
would look like an effect in your
category X in Math Plus. Let's say then
what we want to do is talk about this
function X goes to minus log of e of X,
which we call the Surprise. So we just
introduce this graphical feature where
we draw a green box around it and say
that denotes this function. Now,
and using rules, the nice properties of
logarithm, you can turn these into nice
graphical rules. This log box feature
would satisfy for example, this is sort
of the way that logarithms turn
multiplication into addition on the left
here. If you have this
around, then you can start talking about
surprise. So if you have two
distributions, sigma and Omega, the
surprise of one distribution relative to
the other is defined by this expectation
value. So just the expectation of a
surprise of sigma according to Omega
which if you remember I said expectation
values are given by sort of plugging a
state for the distribution into the
thing you're looking at the expectation
value of. So that would be the log box
here. So we can just define surprise
omega, Sigma in this way if we like in
the pictures. And important special
cases where this come up are when you're
calculating entropy, which is the self
surprise. And the KL divergence can be
calculated from the surprise and the
entropy. So it means that whenever we
have formula given in terms of these if
we like, we can instead denote them with
this graphical symbol, at least with the
log box.
So now let's talk about how we use this
to describe free energy. So what we
wanted to do in the paper is sort of
help clarify the kind of different
notions of free energy that we found in
active instruments. In particular the
variational and the expected free energy
energy. So we want one more general
quantity that we can understand both of
those in terms of. I'm just calling out
the free energy here. I'm interested to
know what other people think of this
sort of naming for what we're doing.
The situation is that we've got some
generative model that's fixed over these
two variables Sno like before. So
remember we had this distribution, this
box M over Sno distribution. And let's
just say we have another distribution Q
now and we'll see examples of this in a
second what sort of Q they would be.
Then we just define this quantity of
free energy of the one relative to the
other in this way. So it's the surprise
minus the entropy of Q in the string
diagrams. Then it's just this feature we
plug. So it's like the expected surprise
of M for Q minus the entropy of Q's
marginal on S. Or this is the formula
if you want to use the conventional
notation which is useful for relating it
to existing approaches. So we can define
this very general free energy quantity
and then we'll meet two special cases of
it that we're interested in, which is
the variational and expected free
energy. It all comes down basically to
having a definition of surprise. You
just need this notion of surprise to
define everything else. So with a
variational free energy. So we have this
fixed model M and we have this soft
observation o like we did before. So
that's this box here and then what we're
doing is we're considering different
possible distributions over S that we
think of as different updates we could
consider for our beliefs. And we define
the variational free energy of any of
those states, those distributions Q as
the special case of the definition from
the previous slide. So it's like the
general free energy where that capital Q
just takes this form. So it just
consists of our new beliefs, lowercase Q
and our observation O.
So in formula you could also just draw
it like this. So you take the surprise
from your model M and you just see how
its expected value for those beliefs and
that observation subtracted the entropy
of Q.
And what you can show is that this VFV
value satisfies this bound of the KL in
relation to this kind of Jeffrey update
of your model with respect to this
observation. In particular, when it's a
sharp observation, then the minimal of
this VFE will be given by the Bayesian
Updating. In general, though, we might
think about what happens. So in general
we can think of minimizing this VFP
quantity as doing this, as finding this
Q that approximates this kind of updates
we were looking at earlier. And yeah,
in the sharp case it will coincide as
all of the notions of Updating do. So
the minimal VFP will be given by the
Bayesian update. But for these soft
observations, it's something else. It's
not exactly either of the two notions
Updating we met earlier. So this is
actually a third notion of updating for
soft observations, which I think is an
interesting way to think about what VFE
minimization is doing. So we just call
this the VFE update. So you've got many
different Q, you could calculate the
sphere quantity for each and you've got
a soft observation O here. So it's some
distribution. And if you find the one
with the minimal value of sphere, you
call that the VFE update. And this
wouldn't be equal to either those Pearl
or Jeffrey style updates that we met.
So that's the VFE which we'll come back
to, the other notion of free energy we
want to talk about, it's the expected
free energy. So that's where we still
have our model M. But rather than an
observation, we think of ourselves as
having some preferences of observations
we'd like to see they're again encoded
in a distribution, though over O. So
that's this C just
with that fixed, we can define this one
quantity called the expected free
energy. So that's given by the free
energy of M compared with this other
generative model where you have used the
same. So this M here would really be the
inverse channel from O to S of M. So
like the Bayesian inverse here, but
where you just assert that the
preference is actually is the prior on
the observation. So you're comparing
these two in terms of this generic free
energy quantity we defined earlier. So
again, you can turn this into formulae.
And there's loads of stuff in active
inference about the different rewritings
of EFE and the ways to interpret them in
terms of uncertainty and risk and so on.
And it has this property that you can
show it will be bounded by the surprise
of those preferences for your model and
it kind of gives you a way to
approximate them as we'll see. So I
won't talk, I don't think I have time to
go too much more into EFE. But the point
really in terms of what this work's done
is just to try and have just one generic
free energy quantity we met earlier
where we can see the VFE and the EFE
both coming up special cases depending
on what we plug in here for the two
distributions.
So what I'd like to do now is to sort of
put some of these pieces together to
show what active inference itself will
kind of look like in terms of string
diagrams. And in particular, what we'll
do is derive this formula that you'll
find in active inference textbooks in a
graphical way and I think quite a
transparent way, that's the claim.
So to do so, we basically need to give a
nice high level conceptual view of what
active inference is. So this is the way
that we do it in the paper. So when
inactive inference, the key thing for
stating all the definitions is that our
model takes the following form at a high
level. So there's some notion of so.
It's like our discrete time model we had
earlier, but just with two time steps.
If you like, each of those time steps
could break down in terms of further
subtime steps. But that won't matter.
We've just obstructed here at this
higher level. So at the higher level,
we just have a notion of the current
time, or maybe like all the time steps
up to the current time, and that's this
S and O here. So there's current states
and current observations and then
there's some notion of future times,
these future states and future
observations. So that could be all the
time steps up to some big number,
something like that, all grouped
together in one of those discrete time
models. And again, we have the policies
and we have the same sort of shape of
model where there's some channels here
which I haven't bothered giving letters
to, but showing the way that the policy
influences the transition from the state
to the future state and observations
from each. So we just have a generative
model where we have policies, we have
states and observations, and we have
future states and future observations.
In active inference, what we're doing is
we're receiving two things. We're
receiving an observation in the current
time and we have some preferences about
what we'd like to see in the future. So
these are each given by these two
distributions, bolton, O over O, and the
preferences C over the future
observations, and then we're doing
updating with those. So I think updating
is just our habits,
the prior over the policies to give our
new distribution over policies which we
can think of as the agent's plan of how
it wants to act. So we're going to try
and do this updating like before to
obtain a new distribution over P. And
that is now telling us how we want to
behave in the future in a way that will
basically you can. Think of it as
saying, we want to explain why we're
seeing what we're currently seeing and
how we're going to obtain what we'd like
in the future.
In the books kind of inference and
various places you can find a formula
like this that there will be justified
as coming from the free energy principle
in some way. It's basically saying you
can do this approximately by making your
plan distribution take the following
form there's a soft max, there's a part
relating to the habits of your model so
that's your prior over policies. These
pi are the individual policies in P and
then there's parts of formula related to
the VFE and the EFE. And what we
wanted to do is see where this formula
comes from in a sort of nice high
level way from the structure of the
diagram. So there are explanations for
this formula there, but I found them
quite hard to follow, to be honest,
because they were talking about the EFE
as being a prior that you then do EFE
kind of minimization on top of. But you
kind of need to do the part about the
present time first before you can do the
EFE. And so what we wanted, this is a
really clear way to see how this just
drops out from the structure of the
model. So that's what I'll try and show
now. So what
we'd like to do then is to do this
approximate updating. We're going to do
the pearl style updating which looked
like this in the pictures. So we want to
get our new plan so our distribution
over policies by updating, by plugging
in our observation and our preferences
and then normalizing everything. So the
thing on the right is what we'd like to
have ideally but we're just going to
have to approximate it in some way.
Let's just take the distribution that's
inside the dash normalization box. Now
this is the thing we'd like to basically
approximate this in the structure of our
model. We can write it like this and
I'll just show then some graphical steps
for how we can apply approximations to
obtain the formula that we saw. And
obviously we won't be able to go through
every detail of the proof but it should
give hopefully just some intuition for
what it's like to actually work with a
string diagram. So that's really why I'm
showing it. So we knew our model take
roughly this form. There's some part
relating to current states and current
observations and also future
observations. I've just called them both
M here, but we just know there's that
part of the model relating to the
present time and future time. And so
what we're going to do is first focus on
this part of the model relating to the
current state and the current
observation. And we want to approximate
what's in that blue dashed box. And what
you can show is that if you do this VFE
updating, that will be approximately
equal to this part of the diagram. So
this Q is given by for each policy doing
this VSE updating, so minimizing your
variation of free energy. So you do that
for each policy. Then you can view the
collection of all of those belief
updates as just one channel from P to S.
So if you think about it back here,
basically for each policy you could plug
in you would obtain just a distribution
now of snow and you could do updating
with respect to that. That's what Q of
that particular policy pi would be and
you put them all together into this one
channel Q and you can show then for each
one, if you do this overall process
where you multiply by this E to the
minus VFD quantity here, it will be
approximately equal to this part of the
diagram. Okay, so that's our
first step and that's how the VfB
entered the picture. Then we've got this
top part of the diagram, we'll collapse
it together and just view this as one
process going into future observations
and our preferences. And we'd like to
approximate what's in this box now. And
this is where the EFB comes in. So you
can basically show because you have
this, the expected free energy
will give you an approximation to this
here where this is basically like an
expectation value for your preferences
for each policy. So this would be like
the density C of those preferences being
plugged into your model for each policy.
So I haven't had time to go into the
full details. These of approximation
steps but they're essentially the same
approximations you'll find in active
inference text and so on, just turned
into the string diagrammatic setting and
we talk about how they come about from
Jensen's inequality and things like
this. So this step where you think about
the future times is called the
prediction step and the previous one was
the perception step. So now we've
rewritten that diagram in terms of some
e to the minus of the VFE and e to the
minus of the EFE as well as our habits.
And remember what we wanted to do was
approximate the normalization of this
whole thing. So that's when you apply
this blue dash box around the whole
thing and now if we do that, this is
exactly the same as the formula we were
after. So we've obtained the formula now
and that's because you're normalizing
something but it's got these e to the
minuses in it. So you can also rewrite
that in terms of this soft max where now
you just replace the E with this log and
the other ones you lose the
exponentials. So this formula, if you
wanted to, if you wrote out the formula
for what this was for each policy, it
would be equal to this down here. So the
claim is that this is a nice way to
derive this formula and is a bit more
transparent than the ones that exist.
So the idea was really just to see we
draw what's going on. Okay, we're doing
updating with the model of this form and
we're trying to do this approximate form
of updating and just see where we're
applying the approximations and from the
structure of the model itself, see how
this formula comes about.
Okay, so that so far basically just
talked about things that are already
there in active inference as it's new
derivation, but it's existing stuff.
Before wrapping up, I'd just like to
also talk about something bit more new
that we do with the string diagrammatic
approach. That's to talk about the way
in which free energy itself is
compositional. So the motivation for
this is that the idea is that we want to
think of this one free energy principle
applying at all levels of a system.
So to do that, you'd want to know that
an agent can say if you've got one of
these big composite generative models,
that it can do its free energy
minimization on the whole thing by doing
it on the parts. Because we want to
ultimately think it just comes down to
each part doing its own bit of free
energy minimization. So that's what we
want to make precise. In particular,
we're going to be talking about the VFE
here really all the time. And if you
recall in the diagrams, it looked like
this. So we use this log boxes and it
just took this particular shape here.
So what we do in the paper in order to
address this compositionality problem is
introduce a notion of this VFE that we
can apply not just to generative models,
but ones which actually have these
inputs as well. So these were what I
called open generative models earlier
because we need to really talk about
pieces of generative models plugging
together and give them a notion of free
energy to even make sense of this notion
of free energy being compositional. So
we proposed this definition of what we
call the open VFE. So now instead of
just a distribution M over S and O, we
have a channel from some inputs to S and
O given by one of these open models.
And our Q, the thing we're doing the VFE
minimization with respect to. So the
thing we're calculating, it would now
have an input as well. So it's a joint
distribution over the states and inputs
and observation takes the same shape as
before. So you get this other formula
that's basically just a natural way to
generalize the previous VFE formula to
accommodate this extra input wire. I now
and what we show is that this thing is
compositional in a sensor that I alluded
to. So I'll walk through that and the
way you do it is just using these
graphical properties that these log
boxes have that I mentioned earlier. So
you could turn all of that into a proof
and standard probability notation if you
like. But it's quite instructive to
always just be able to work in the
diagrams to keep track of the
compositional structure of the models
and so on. So the result says that
this open VFE quantity is compositional
in two ways. The first one here is this
quite trivial way. So if we have two
models running in parallel, so like
taking the tensor of them and they're
just both doing their own, we're
calculating the VF for each of them.
Sorry for the whole thing, but it's just
given by two running in parallel, then
it's just the same as calculating the V
of V for each individually and adding
them together. So that certainly what
we'd like to happen. And it just follows
from the properties of these log boxes.
More interestingly, there's the second
way in which it's compositional, which
is the sequential mode of plugging
models together. So if we have an open
model M one and some inputs into some
outputs one, but those are now actually
the inputs for the second model and we
have these running. So the first
generation model is passing stuff up to
the second one. And now we want to
calculate that result VFE in
terms of an observation. We can again
write it as a sum of two of them, but in
a slightly different way. So observation
is just existing on the top wire,
right? Because it's just the output of
the whole thing that gets this
observation. So it's just on O two. So
first we calculate the VFE for this
model at the top m two in the usual way
and then we add on a Vfe calculated for
the first model, but it doesn't really
have an observation one, right? But
instead the observation it uses is one
that's being passed down from M two. So
that's the queue that M two is using is
passed down now as if it's an
observation down to M one. So it's kind
of like O two receives this observation,
does its updating about Q or whatever,
and passes that down to M one.
So in this way we can say that the VFE
composers in that okay, both of these
are minimizing VFE locally, where for
the M one model we mean it's minimizing
it with respect to these cues that are
coming, for these O ones that are coming
down from above. Then the whole system
is also minimizing its VFE because it's
just given by summing those two
together. So I talked about
a lot of stuff. Now I'm just going to
wrap up now and then we can go to a
discussion, I hope. So the main takeaway
was just meant to be to try and show
that these string diagrams provide some
natural language for talking about
active inference. And I would encourage
you to try anyone working on active
inference formally to take a look and
see if they would be useful to you in
some way. And in particular, I focused
on some of the what I was calling the
main ingredients of active inference,
so that were generative models, the way
you update them, and free energy. And we
saw sort of ways you can describe all of
those notions in the string diagrams.
And the thing that I think is useful
about them is that they give you a nice
representational language for just
drawing pictures of your generative
models and composing them like
hierarchical models and so on. But they
also let you do the reasoning because
you can do probability theory with them.
So you can actually reason about what's
going on in active inference just with
the diagrams themselves. There's loads
of directions. You can take this in the
future. Obviously we could keep
absorbing more of the work without the
native inference into the diagrams. Bit
more interestingly, we introduced
this new notion at the end of how to
make free energy compositional. In
particular, we gave this definition of
VFE for an open system now so it has a
generative model which can have inputs.
We call this the open Vfe. I just be
very interested in what people think of
this definition we introduced and
whether it seems meaningful. Secondly,
well, throughout the talk I kept talking
about just minimizing free energy and
that's all I said already, the Vfe. I
didn't say how you do it. So in fact,
this is normally done with these various
algorithms of message passing
algorithms. So they're an important part
of active inference as well. And I think
it would be great to include these in
the setup by having some diagrammatic
story of them. There's lots of other
questions around. So one of them is that
I talked about these two notions of
updating with respect to soft
observations. And I think normally
people tend to focus on sharp
observations, so they perhaps haven't.
Not everyone has heard of these before,
but it's very natural to treat the soft
ones when you're working this
compositional setup. And so there you
start to wonder about which of these,
the Pearl style updating or the Jeffrey
style updating is more natural to think
about in the context of cognition. And
maybe we'll say, okay, well really VSE
updating is the one you should be
thinking about. That's probably the
claim accurate inference would make,
but it'd still be nice to think about
how this relates to the other two. Is it
best thought of as approximating the
former or the latter style of sort of
precise updating? And then finally we.
Could try and connect this up to lots of
further topics. I mentioned I'm a
continuum, and we're interested in this
notion of compositional intelligence.
So it would be nice to connect this now
to topics in AI and so on, and think
about how it relates to other,
basically applications of category
theory in AI. In particular. There's
also this whole world of categorical
cybernetics I mentioned at the
beginning, and I'd like to connect this
a bit more precisely with what people
are doing there with their stories in
terms of lenses and so on. And something
else we were also interested in that I
mentioned is that we got into the topic
by thinking about consciousness. And
there's lots of ways, as a major theory
of cognition, there's been just loads of
proposals for how active inference is
related to consciousness, and it'd be
nice to see how those can be described
formally and in this setup and whether
the string diagrammatic approach helps
you make any more sense of those. So
that's something we'd love to do in
future. But for now, I'd like to say
thanks again to all of you for
listening, and I'd love to go to a
discussion. Thanks.
Thank you, Sean, for the wonderful
presentation. Thank you.
I will first pass to Ali for
an opening remark,
please.
Thank you, Daniel. Thanks so much,
Sean, for your really fascinating
presentation. I truly enjoyed it.
So I have a number of questions.
Let me begin by asking the first
know. When Bob Kirky and others took
Hamiltonian formulation of quantum
mechanics and kind of turned it into
the string diagram formulation of it,
namely ZX calculus, the claim was
that regardless of its possible verity,
but the claim was that one of the
advantages of looking at quantum
mechanics in terms of string diagrams,
it's more than just a convenient way of
looking at quantum formulation, and it
actually unveils some properties of
quantum mechanics that would be
extremely difficult to see with
Hamiltonian formulation. And even in
some of their papers, they claim one
of the reasons for somehow
the stagnant development in
quantum technologies and quantum theory
is exactly related to the difficulty of
working with Hamiltonian formulations.
So would you say string diagram
formulation of active inference kind of
takes a similar approach to somehow
providing more than just handy tool
for representing active inference
modeling. And actually it kind of
opens up new possibilities for further
developments of active inference theory,
possibilities which would somehow, I
don't know, impossible or at least
extremely difficult for the current
traditional formulation of active
inference to see in the current
formulation of the active inference.
Thanks. That's an amazing question.
Yeah, I would agree. I think my
idea for work at Oxford is actually in
this categorical quantum mechanics area
I talked about so string diagrams for
quantum theory and everything. And I
agree that that language helps you talk
about a lot of things that you would
maybe never get round to so much in
other mathematical formulations of
quantum theory, basically things that
make use of the tensor, as it were, the
composition a lot. So if this led to
stagnation in quantum theory, it's
probably because people weren't focusing
as much on the tensor and entanglement
and stuff, which became very central.
Obviously in the end that's what people
needed to do, quantum computing and
stuff. So now what people are doing with
quantum theories includes quantum
computing where they're drawing these
circuits and so you're drawing they're
basically like string diagrams
describing sometimes these string
diagrams, sometimes they just use the
slightly different conventions for
quantum circuits. But it's similarly a
compositional language where you have
got tensor products. So that as in
things running in parallel states of
these products so that you can talk
about entanglement and so on. It's the
language that makes it very immediate to
represent that, because you just draw a
box with two eyes and it encodes
entangled state, and it makes you want
to plug these things together and
compose them, which is what you want to
do in quantum computing. So I think
similarly, if you never use that kind of
language, you might think of a system
often as a fixed thing and not about the
way it interacts with other ones so much
and that could lead to overlooking all
sorts of things. So that's true in any
area. And I think in active inference
it's certainly very true. I think that
it's natural to think compositionally in
this way because you're wanting to talk
about generative models being composed
from pieces and you're maybe thinking
about how the whole brain works in
relation to interactions between parts
of it and so on. So if you never used
this kind of compositional view, there
is stuff you would miss, I think. I
think in some sense people weren't as
behind already because they already were
working kind of compositionally right,
because they're using these Bayesian
network diagrams like the Dags and the
way they're normally drawn are very
close. They are basically the string
diagrams, they just don't do the
equations and the rewriting of the
diagrams. So it's not as far back maybe
as quantum theory was, in the sense that
people are thinking compositionally,
but it feels like you just want to go
one step further to having a fully
compositional language you're working
in. Where you have the advantage now
that you can just talk about taking a
whole model and plugging it into another
one and it has a completely clear formal
meaning and so on, which I think is what
you want to do in areas like active
inference. So going from the diagrams
which are currently used to string
diagrams is like the logical next step
and in terms of new stuff it lets you
do. I think an example is something like
this open BFE thing, I guess. So if
you're just always thinking about just a
generative model meaning one without
inputs. You might not think of a notion
I'm not saying this is necessarily the
right notion, but you might not think
about this problem of how you want to
give your definition for something that
is allowed to have inputs as well. And
once you have that have definition, you
can sort of apply to parts of a
composite system more easily, so it
becomes more natural to
use compositionally. So that's the kind
of thing where without something like
string diagrams, people can end up
overlooking it. It wouldn't be
impossible to do without them. I just
need to talk about this notion of a kind
of open generative model, which just
means throwing away some mechanisms to
make things be inputs. But you could
miss it, but you really won't once you
start thinking categorically.
Thank you, Ollie. Please continue if you
would like.
Thanks. So, yeah, my other
perhaps related question is comparing
this kind of formulation to this recent
formulation of constructor theory in
terms of string diagrams or categorical
formulation of constructor theory.
Before going into this question, you
see, you mentioned that this
project is a part of a larger
project for developing collective
intelligence, right? So the similar
kind of situation happens for
constructor theory in which it is a
kind of meta theory that tries to
somehow discriminate
between the possibilities of
physical laws as opposed to
counterfactual laws, and how
physical laws, how there
can be a theory, accounts for the
emergence of possible physical laws.
So in this sense,
would you say this kind of formulation
category, theoretical formulation, or
possibly this specific String diagram
formulation of active inference? Or
maybe other theories of consciousness
can be seen as a kind of providing a
path? Toward developing a kind of meta
theory of consciousness and possibly
unifying many different strands of
theories of consciousness into.
I. Don'T know, a holistic picture that
can somehow be compared and
positively reconciled with one
another and ultimately reaching the
ultimate theory of consciousness. Or,
I don't know, do you see this line of
work providing
enough evidence for this line of
development research or, I don't
know, somehow maybe even
not specifically consciousness, but
unifying the different aspects of
cognition, intelligence and
consciousness altogether?
What would you say? Thanks. Keep giving
me ideal selling points. So, yeah,
that's also something I would like to
say.
I tend to think of it that way and that
my background is in applying category
theory to just lots of topics and I so
naturally do think of it as quite a
unifying language. And the grant on
consciousness that I mentioned was
building on earlier work we did on
looking at integrated information theory
of consciousness, which in the end
basically was done in terms of
categorical probability. So it's like
the same setup of the diagrams. And so
we kind of wanted to do the same thing
for directive inference. So there
it's like we've taken both of these
things and put them in this common
language. You could have put them in the
common language of probability theory
before. But I think I do have an
intuition that there is something more
clear about it. Does make it easier to
get a conceptual grasp of both theories,
I think, once you've done it this way
and somehow also, yeah, the diagrammatic
view does make it much easier to compare
them. So the hope was basically to, and
still is to keep going and to keep
understanding various notions in that
language. So there's things I've looked
at in cognitive science I've also done
this way. So this theory of conceptual
spaces, garden force have worked on
treating that in terms of diagrams and
so on. So I would love to see basically
many theories put into this language to
make it easier to compare them. You
could try and compare them directly
already, but I think you want one clear
formalization to put them all in. And I
would say that the categories and
diagrams is the right one to pick
because it tends to just give a very
clear conceptual view of things. The
question is whether you have some theory
that's very important, where the things
categories are good at, just doesn't
quite capture the essence of what you
want to talk about there. But for things
like active inference and IIT, so far it
seemed very natural because on the case
of IIT, it's about talking about how
integrated something is. So you
basically want to talk about the
opposite of that, which is something
being decomposed. And the diagrams
basically talk about parts and how
they're related, which is what you need
to make sense of that notion of
integration. So it's very natural there.
But yeah, I would love basically to see
various aspects of cognitive science
understood categorically. That's
something I'd love to do myself as well.
And the hope would be then to
try and gain insights from all of them
and build a theory. It's not the
category theory itself is a theory of
cognition or consciousness. It's just a
very useful language for relating them.
And then it would be very exciting to
see something natively defined in terms
of category theory as well at the end.
And there's a feeling that some of
what's going on in applied category
theory, I think, like in categorical,
cybernetics and so on, is kind of taking
that approach for perhaps some of the
first time. Previously, I've always
thought category theory is basically you
take existing things and you get a
really nice abstract view of them. But
now I think people are comfortable
enough with it that they're sort of
defining things categorically from the
outset in areas like that.
Awesome. Well.
Yeah, I have many thank you. These are
great questions. There's like ideal
questions.
You'Ve pointed in. And we've explored a
little bit of the utility and the
simplicity and how that could help with
accessibility and rigor and
applicability all these awesome things
leading to reaccounting and reframing
consolidating as well as discovering
some new trails between, for example,
expected free energy energy and
variational free energy energy. Looking
at the equations, you might be able to
say that they rhyme, but you would be
many, many lines deep into understanding
what, if any, generalizations could
encompass the both of them. So that was
just a very salient example.
A few different kinds of questions.
So how is time treated in category
theory? Or how does active inference
treat time today and how do you see the
way that time is treated? We talk about
discrete time and continuous time
generative models. Then there's the
past, present and future multi agent
systems federated or asynchronous
communication. So how is time treated
and how does that give us a different
grasp on dynamical modeling?
Thank you. I'd love to have
a better answer for that. Basically, I
think it's a tough one at the moment in
the talks if I just talked about
discrete time and that's sort of very
easy to treat with the Bayesian network
setup and with these kind of string
diagrams because you can just lay out
the discrete time steps as processes in
your picture like we see here. We have
the end time steps here, but I
don't have anything satisfying worked
out yet to say about how you would treat
a continuous time case, which I think is
important in active inference. You'd
like to basically take.
I guess basically what you want to do is
take the way that you describe this
thing with the end time steps and kind
of have a formula for folding it
together and just saying, okay, but
you're unpacking this. Thing n times.
And then you can take that thing and
imagine this abstract view of unpacking.
It just not discreetly anymore in this
continuous way, so that you can capture
something like the differential equation
kind of definition of continuous time
thing in active inference.
I? Yeah so
you can certainly work with continuous
time things in the sense of, you know,
the stuff going on in categorical
cybernetics or sort of categorical
systems theory I guess it would be
called. Act world is kind know
it has continuous time dynamical systems
and talks about plugging them together
but that diagram is sort of just
relating their variables is my
understanding. It's not like a diagram
isn't exactly showing the time and in
some sense they kind of have to
synchronize, I think. It's not an area
I'm totally familiar with. So it would
have been really cool to basically have
this work and then have another part of
it talking about like we've done for
discrete time here. Having a nice
description of a continuous time case,
I think it will end up being some work
to take that into account there would
be really nice to see. So it just needs
the right abstraction, I think, for
taking a picture like this. Not drawing
the time steps as like bits in your
diagram, but just saying that it's like
this b thing with like a feedback loop
basically is what this is describing.
And then giving a semantics to that in
terms of time evolution, to give a
continuous version of this, for example,
with like state unfurling continuously
and observations for each time step
in general. I wouldn't say there's like
an answer to the question of how is time
treated in category theory. There
wouldn't really be one answer because
category is going to be so generally
they tend to be very effective for
discrete things in general, like algebra
and so on, because they kind of are
discrete in some sense, like the
composition is discrete. So continuous
aspects and things like continuous time
tend to be more difficult in a sense.
Or they're just sort of inside the
morphisms, as it were. They're not in
the composition. So it doesn't end up
looking like this when you're composing
continuously.
But yeah, I think there will be people
in act who sort of would
come at you with a particular answer.
So they've got a way they like to treat
continuous time that I'm
just not familiar with yet. Cool.
A little bit of a more educational or
applied question. So how do we go about
drawing and learning to draw? Is there a
software package? Is there a way that we
can get a step by step process to
building that familiarity with like when
I see this shape, then here's what I
know. And then how do we know what we
can and can't do? And does that drawing
software flag us or do
we need to send it to a friend? So how
do we look at something? And then part
one, build up the motifs in our own
aesthetic understanding so that we can
understand the compositionality of this
as you do today and as we all do today,
for example, for Language English. And
then part two, how do we go from having
built that motif based compositional
understanding to like now what
can we do? And then when are we just
totally freewheeling and off the rails
of the free energy principle? Or does
anything go if the motifs allow it?
Yeah, I wish I should have the standard
answer. The best way to learn string
diagrams, I think, if I'm going to talk
about it like this. So you prompted me
to come up with that. I don't have
something on top of my head. That's the
best way. But there's so much stuff out
there I think it tends to be because if
you want to get really comfortable with
the diagrams, you're learning category
theory in some sense, but it's not like
you need to learn all of category
theory. It's kind of a relatively modern
offshoot in this applied category theory
world that's very diagrammatically
focused and there will be various nice
introductions out there to using them
another way is to
think I'm pretty sure recently yeah,
there was a nice paper that came out,
there was an introduction to string
diagrams for computer scientists, for
example. So there tends to be different
introductions kind of for different
audiences because they just want to pick
categories that
those people are familiar with. Right.
So they can actually have some examples.
You could just learn the diagrams
totally abstractly, but it helps to have
some examples. And the old category free
textbooks are all things mathematicians
have looked at and other people haven't
heard of, so they're not particularly
helpful. So there's know Bob has paper
categories for the practicing physicist
that's aimed at physicists that would
basically introduce string diagrams to
them. There's this recent computer
science one. I know there's some work
going on in producing one for cognitive
science, which I think would be really
good having an introduction to
the string diagrams for those people.
So you basically look for one in an area
you're comfortable with and you find a
good paper on it. But it would be nice
to have a good online resource, I guess,
right, that gathers these together so
people can just see a great guide for
all the introductions. If you do
something like there's courses you can
do in the sense of the Bob's book.
In the case of learning quantum,
there's something like Bob's Long book
with Alex Kissinger picturing quantum
processes. That's the kind of thing I
learned from like it was in the form of
a lecture course. But it's basically the
same book because then there's just
loads of exercises that will make you
have to reason with string diagrams and
then you pick the rules up because at
first you don't have the same intuition,
obviously, but the rules what can I do
with these? Can I slide them around like
this or whatever? But it doesn't take
too long to get quite used to it, I
think, which is the nice thing about
them. They're kind of natural, they're
just these elastic strings and boxes and
you have that sort of geometrical
intuition. So things like that with
exercises are the way I'd recommend
getting used to using them. I didn't use
any software in a sense of the diagrams
I draw in this program called Tixit,
but it doesn't tell you how string
diagrams will work or anything, it's
just for drawing them.
But I know there's more work to develop.
Libraries like the Algebraic Julia
project is sort of like an applied
category theory language,
but I wouldn't know if it was
recommended as a way to first learn
categories.
Yeah. So I would recommend finding a
nice introductory paper in whatever
field you're most used to playing with
some exercises to get really used to
them. For causal models, there's this
paper Robin and I put out. It's not
necessarily the very first place to
learn string diagrams, but the aim is to
introduce to people who've heard of
causal models. So in a sense of pearl.
So just Bayesian networks, basically,
but maybe the course interpretation of
them to get them used to string
diagrams. And this paper hopes to be a
little bit introductory as well.
Cool. Ali, please.
Thank you. So getting back to the
question about the time representation
in this formulation. So I
take it that this kind of formulation
of Bayesian inference, I mean, category
theoretical formulation of Bayesian
inference is largely based on tobi's
Fritz definition of Markov categories
as CD categories. Right.
So as far as I understand it,
Fritz paper kind of one
of its basic assumptions is this kind of
unidirectional inference, I mean,
from earlier times to later times,
right, or in other words, the
prediction. But in
quantum formulation of active inference
or quantum active inference,
there's this attempt to also develop the
retradiction aspect of inference as
well. Right. So would you say this
recent formulation can also be accounted
for, this kind of retradiction? In other
words, can this formulation be
reconciled with quantum Bayesianism as
well? Yeah, I basically wish yeah,
sorry, go ahead. Because to add one more
context here, I think
it was in Kirk and Speckin's paper,
there was this clear distinction between
classical Bayesian inference and non
classical Bayesian inference, in which
the classical one does not allow
for the retrodiction, but non classical
Bayesian inference can be applied for
both prediction and retrodiction as
well. Okay, yeah, I would
love to be a bit more familiar with the
quantum active inference stuff,
basically, to compare a bit. So I'm not
as familiar with the sort of retro
sorry, what was the other version of
prediction? It's retro. Retrodiction,
yeah, prediction and retradiction.
I would have to compare with this. I
know the paper you mean Bob's Paper Frog
on both forms of Asian inference to see
what they say there about the classical
one. Can you give some intuition as to
why it isn't something you can do
classically, basically, the retro one?
Because if that's a general case about
probabilities, then it will be true in
some sense here. Right. So here it's
just being modeled in this probabilistic
category. And so at the moment they're
separate in that you have the model
which basically goes forward and then
you do your updating to try and
approximate something going back. But
you don't really have like this one.
The whole idea was that for predictive
quantum mechanics, we only need to
account for the inference from earlier
times to later times. But if we want
to account for retrodictive quantum
mechanics as well, we need to somehow
account for because as we know,
not every quantum formulation
follows the Bell's principle of local
causality.
In order to account for all the
entanglement phenomenon so on, we need
to somehow put this bi directional
inference into our model.
So, yeah, that was the basic idea
behind developing this kind of non
classical Bayesian inference. Does it
have something to do with the unitary
evolution in quantum theory the way that
you have this reversible thing? Or is it
exactly that
was the gist of it, yeah. And so you
don't expect to have something like that
classically, basically, where you have
this reversible thing built in. Well,
yeah, so I wouldn't expect to see that
exact feature here in the sense of if
it's treated, if it's basically
something that you can't have in
classical probabilities, it won't exist
in this category matar plus. I think
that would be basically the same
category they would use in that paper,
and they work with dagger combat
categories, and they'll work with
something like this Matar Plus category.
But the classical case,
if it's just a general it's less of a
sort of physical notion, but it's just
an idea that the model comes with a
forward part and a backward part, then I
think that's the kind of here how you go
from a forward part to approximate this
backward thing. But the sort of lens
type view of what's going on that's more
studied in category cybernetics would be
imagining. I think the model kind of
carrying this backward inference process
with it as well, so that for each
forward part of the model, you would
have this approximate inference sort of
channel stored with it. So I don't know
if that would address what you're
asking, but it would have a backward and
forward part together.
Well, Ollie, do you have any kind of
closing opening remarks or questions or
where do you see this going from the
active inference side? What does this
bring to us and what is
opened through what has happened
largely this year in active inference
and category theory? Well, actually,
I'm really excited to see this line of
development in active inference theory.
And as you know, I'm a big, big fan of
meta theories and all kinds of
unification theories and so on.
I don't know, I kind of have
this feeling, have this hunch that this
line of development in active inference
theory, it looks quite promising,
especially for kind
of tying up all the loose ends and
transcending many, many other areas and
discourses and ultimately reaching a
kind of coherent picture of quote
unquote reality, whatever it means.
So, yeah, these kinds of development, I
mean, the last year we had tremendous
advances in Bayesian mechanical
theories, and in recent months
we have this fabulous line of research
in category theoretical account of
active inference. My hope is that
ultimately these different strands can
be unified into coherent
and overarching framework. So exciting
times.
So do you mean that you're thinking of
it as it sounded like you're basically
alluding to the work going on in
cognition and work going on in physics
coming together. Right. Like one really
meta really open. Exactly,
yeah. The idea behind Bayesian
mechanics, one of its premises or
assertions was that there isn't any
clear distinction between cognitive
and non cognitive things or agents and
they rest on a continuum.
The same kind of mathematical technology
can be applied both for inert and
conscious agents or sentient agents or
whatever we choose to call them. So,
yeah, this overarching theory unveiled
many interesting phenomena regarding,
well, self organizing systems, and it
changed the whole perspective about how
we can look at and even define
consciousness, cognition, intelligence,
sentience, and all of these related
terms. So my hope is that category
theoretical account of active inference
can also be used for
clearly seeing many of these emerging
elements in Bayesian mechanics and
active inference theory and hopefully,
well, gaining some interesting and
potentially groundbreaking insights.
That'd be wonderful. Yeah,
I'd love to apply for those topics, and
I'd be very curious to see how
categories can come in. Sorry, Daniel.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. I'll just give my
closing thoughts then to you, Sean.
Just a few loose notes that, again,
open probably more than they close. Ali
was right in suggesting and expressing
that Bayesian mechanics recently has
helped us develop a continuum of active
and passive systems, so called living
and non living, or inanimate and
animate. And that brings us to another
dialectic to resolve, which is life and
mind, which is where the physical and
the cognitive science come together.
You said they're on a continuum. Maybe
we could say they're on a quantinium.
And what language could express such
work? Well, right now we're speaking in
English with the active inference
ontology dialect. However, the phonemes
are not intrinsically meaningful. The M
in a Markov blanket or category does not
mean something. It's a sound.
And so the string diagram
language and representation I see as a
way to fuse and integrate
semantics into the syntax of the actual
inscription, which enables us
to generalize in new ways.
Also, recognizing string diagrams are
not everything, and so on. And then
with all of these intersecting vectors
from the cognitive and the physical
sciences, we are able to
take the compositional cartographic
approach for cognitive ecosystems and
talk about diverse intelligences,
biological, quantum, classical
architectures, all of these synthetic
intelligences. And so it's super
exciting, and I appreciate again your
visit and look forward to people's
curiosity taking them and also the
development of tools and educational
materials that make this easier and then
being able to display and use something
where the meaning is
primal rather than like, well, this
letter represents this.
It already introduces such a space
between the analytical representation
and really the string
diagram, which exists isomorphically
with it.
Yes, I find this very exciting way of
thinking. It sounds like you're
advocating a kind of structural ontology
kind of thing in some sense, right,
where you're taking the compositional
structure of what's going on to really
be the meaning or really be the real
thing that's there, not just like I
don't know. Yeah, we could talk about it
for a while, I imagine, but I would love
to see string diagrams and other
approaches. I'm sure that take that
role. And you've got me very excited
about this kind of unification that's
going on. Thank you again,
Sean. You're always welcome, and we look
forward to seeing where this all goes.
Yeah. Thanks again for having me. Yeah.
Really great discussion. Thank you.
Thank you so much. Thanks, Ali. All
right. Bye.